The second model for providing
virtualization of physical devices is to
allow the hypervisor to first
intercept every single possible device
access that's performed by a guest VM.
Once the hypervisor has the information
about the device operation
that the guest VM wanted to perform,
it doesn't have a requirement that
the device that the guest VM wants and
the physical device match.
So the hypervisor would first translate
that device access to some generic
representation of an I/O operation for
that particular family of devices,
whether they are networked devices or
disk devices.
And then it will traverse the hypervisor
resident, the VMM resident I/O stack.
So the bottom of that stack is
the actual real device driver,
and the hypervisor will
invoke that device driver and
perform the I/O operation
on behalf of the guest VM.
Clearly, a key benefit
of this approach is that
now the virtual machine is again
decoupled from the physical device.
Any translation, any emulation, will
be performed by the hypervisor layer.
And because of that, operations
such as sharing and migration, or
the requirements of how we need
to deal with device specifics,
all of that becomes simpler in a sense.
This is a model that's originally
adapted by the VMware ESX hypervisor.
The downside of the model is
that it clearly adds latency
on device accesses because
of this emulation step.
And then also it requires
that the device driver
ecosystem is in certain ways
integrated with the hypervisor.
Now the hypervisor need to
support all of the drivers so
that it can perform
the necessary operations.
And the hypervisor is then exposed
to all of the complexities of, and
bugs of various device drivers.
Again, we said earlier
in the case of VMware,
because of its market share,
this model was a reasonable model,
and it made sense and
it's been sustained because of that.